[موسيقى]
قتلت فتاه تشبهها لتلفق خبر وفاتها
جريمه هزت الشارع الالماني في اغسطس
الماضي لكن الادعاء العام كشفت تفاصيل
صادمه 2022
من اصول عراقيه
عن المفقوده عثر على سيارتها وبداخلها جثه
بلا معالم اعتقدوا انها للفتاه المفقوده
لكن الصدمه جاءت في اليوم التالي بعد
تحليلات الحمض النووي تبين ان الجثه تعود
لفتاه اخرى
واسمها خديجه تشبه كثيرا الفتاه المفقوده
التي عثرت الشرطه عليها لاحقا واحتجزتها
على ذمه التحقيق
وفق الشرطه فان المتهمه رتبت وفاتها
المزوره وقررت الاختفاء بسبب مشاكل عائليه
من النساء اللواتي يشبهنها عبر تطبيق
انستغرام
تواصلت المتهمه ما عدد من الفتيات اللواتي
كانت لديهن ملامح وتشبهوها وقع لاختيار
على فتاه ذات اصول عربيه عمرها 23 عاما
اقنعتها بضروره لقائهما مقابله وعودا
زائفه لم توضح الشرطه تفاصيلها
بعد اللقاء استدرجت المتهمه والصديق اخر
لها الضحيه الى غابه وطعنها عشرات المرات
بهدف تلفيقه خبر وفاتها